اكثر من مليونين مدني فلسطيني في قطاع غزه
لا يزالون تحت وطاه القصف الاسرائيلي الذي
يستهدف مناطق واحياء ذات كثافه سكانيه
عاليه هنا حي النصر بمدينه غزه استهدفت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه شقه في احد المباني
ما ادى الى استشهاد واصابه عدد من
الفلسطينيين من بينهم قيادي في سرايا
القدس وفق ما افادت مصادر في الجهاد
الاسلامي
واشتعلت النيران في المكان ما صعب من
عمليه انتشال المصابين من تحت انقاض الشقه
في الحي المقتض بالسكان في دير البلح وسط
قطاع غزه استهدفت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه
منزل احدى العائلات ودمرته بالكامل
مخيم سيرات شماليه دير البلح بدوره تعرض
لغارات اسرائيليه وفي بلده بيت حانون
شماليه قطاع غزه دمر القصف الاسرائيلي
منزل عائله ابو خاطر كما قصفت طائرات
الاحتلال شرقيه رفح وزعمت ان احد مواقع
القصف تابع لقائد كتيبه رفح في الجهاد
الاسلامي
كما استهدف جيش الاحتلال منزلا سكنيا في
مخيم جباليا شمال شرقي القطاع ويتزامن
القصف مع تحليق مكثف لطائرات الاستطلاع
والمسيرات الاسرائيليه فوق غزه وفي تطور
بارز اطلقت المقاومه الفلسطينيه صواريخ
بعيده المدى باتجاه مستوطنات جنوبي وغربي
القدس المحتله بمدى وصل الى نحو 65
كيلومترا
وتحدثت انباء عن اعتراض منظومه مقلاع
داوود صاروخا فوق الجبال الجنوبيه للقدس
المحتله واظهرت مقاطع مصوره حاله الهلع
التي اصابت الاسرائيليين وشمل الاستهداف
مستوطنات غوشسيون وبيطار عيديتش جنوب غربي
بيت لحم كما اعترضت القبه الحديديه صاروخا
فوق بيت شامج غرب القدس المحتله وبقيت
مستوطنات غلاف غزه في مرمى صواريخ
المقاومه حيث استهدفت مستوطنات سنيرات
وكفار عزه وعسقلان ونير عوز وهاشلوشاه
واشكو